hello everyone and welcome to today's
live keynote presentation treating with
cannabis presented by Jeff hergenrother
indie consultation physician president
of the Society of cannabis clinicians
vice president of the American Academy
of cannabinoid Medicine Northern
California I am Christina mahalik of
laberd's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know you're having a problem this
presentation is educational unless
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Hogan rather I will now turn the
presentation to over attend hat hello
thank you for the introduction I'm a
practicing physician in Northern
California I've been doing cannabis
consultations for about 20 years
my experience with cannabis really dates
back about 40 years but since California
changed our laws in 1996 I'd be
to use cannabis as a part of my practice
and a couple years later opened an
office specifically doing cannabis
consultations and have done that since
then I am in a solo private practice and
I have no financial relationships to
disclose so though I may mention types
of products I I do not have any
financial relationships with these so I
think one place to start would be to
simply say that things to Qing instil in
United States last few years at this
time in polling the public nearly
seventy percent of Americans live in
states that have reformed their
marijuana laws by allowing medical
marijuana and polls are showing that
sixty percent of Americans support
making marijuana use legal altogether
and about ninety percent support
allowing medical marijuana things
changed a lot in 2013 when CNN chief
neurosurgeon and correspondent through
the network came on and told the story
about a young child in Colorado who had
had a seizure has a seizure disorder and
he realized after looking into this case
that this girl was benefiting enormous
lis from the use of a high CBD form of
cannabis half after the presentation he
went on to say that he'd been terribly
and systematically misled for nearly 70
years in the United States or we have
been terribly and systematically misled
for nearly 70 years in the United States
and he apologizes for his own role in
that so he really turned his opinion
around in seeing the use of cannabis in
a childhood seizure disorder this seemed
to correspond to the public
feeling a lot more comfortable asking
the question of what about marijuana
what about cannabis as a use useful
medicine not only for seizure disorders
for but for all kinds of disorders
the public has changed the laws now in
many states we have 23 states with
medical marijuana and six more that have
medical and/or adult use of medical
marijuana
so 29 states now have approved the use
of cannabis on a regular basis there are
some limited access states that are
allowing the high CBD strains of
cannabis the ones with very reduced
psychoactivity
in another 16 states so there are only
five states now that have no medical use
and even they are talking about changing
their rules yet we still have no change
at the federal government so we're still
working in a climate of prohibition the
only state that changed the laws by by
way of their legislature is Vermont
which is interesting so what I'm saying
is it's the public that has changed the
laws and it's the opinions in the public
that have really come around a long way
because people realize and find that
cannabis is so useful for so many things
or they hear about it in their friends
and relatives well this is a map it's
only a missing West Virginia as being
shown here as a no medical marijuana
state in fact it does have a medical
marijuana law now and that was just
about a year ago when they changed their
their law so you can see except for the
gray states there is cannabis use
becoming more or less all over the
country this whole issue about cannabis
as a medicine comes from our knowledge
of the endocannabinoid system this is a
system that's built into the body that
brings us into balance we didn't know
about it for until really the last 20 or
30 years when a cannabis like molecule
was radioactively-labeled and injected
into the body and it went to very
specific locations this gave us some
information about where this system
could be found and it shows up in our in
our neurologic system in the brain
and in the nerves and it also shows up
in the immune system it is made up of
receptors that I would describe just
about like this and ligands or molecules
that activate these receptors that fit
into these receptors on the surfaces of
cells in the immune system and in the
nervous system so what are the roles of
this natural system it helps us to eat
and to sleep and relax both physically
and mentally
they forget you know good kind of way
and extinguishes bad memories it helps
us to get fear and pain off of our minds
it is very important in in the way we
learn and forget protection it protects
in many ways so the immune system is
basically scouting around in the body
looking for problems and programming
cell death of abnormal cells so it has a
role in protecting cells protecting
nerves and in and killing cancer cells
as well so what I'm showing you here is
that the endocannabinoid system is seen
from Hydra to sea squirts fish really
all throughout the animal kingdom
perhaps with the exception of insects we
don't really have much evidence that
there be insects have an endocannabinoid
system but all other animals in the
animal kingdom do see it in the genes
and this has been preserved for millions
and millions of years of development as
we've evolved along this particular
system is key to our survival and it can
be activated by cannabis so going back
to the radioactively-labeled cannabinoid
you can see the areas that are
highlighted in reds and orange and
yellow are the areas most concentrated
in the cannabinoid receptors in the body
and are in the brain so the middle row
of column is the MRI scan and the
right-hand column is a blend of the
receptors with the MRI images
so you can see that the brain is rich in
these receptors and they have very
specific roles depending on where they
are in the brain in the rest of the body
this was injecting a cannabinoid into
the body at with the radioactive tracer
and we see it at the time of injection
showing up immediately in the liver the
bright red spot on the on the left side
of this BOTS image and in the skeleton
it's showing up so as the minutes go
along it goes from zero up to a hundred
and two minutes you can see that these
receptors again are lighting up wherever
they are in the body they are primarily
in the immune system in the body looking
again for trouble if you will so on the
cb1 side the ones that are in the
central nervous system we know that
they're not only in the brain in the
concentrations that I was indicating but
they also go in the nerves throughout
the body into all of these different
locations and on the cb2 receptors a
slightly different receptor but closely
a very close approximation of the cb1
receptor it's in these immune cells the
monocytes the macrophages the P cells
and B cells liver spleen and tonsils all
involved in immune responses they're
also cluster in the brain and in the
gastrointestinal tract so what are the
roles of these cannabinoids when they're
activated when the when the natural
cannabinoids the ones that are built in
that are very similar to the plant
cannabis cannabinoids they activate
these receptors and provide these
various pharmacologic effects this is
not an entirely complete list but it
gives you a pretty good idea of what all
they can do so by activating the
receptor we have pain relief and ease
fast [ __ ] effects anti anorectic
which means they help the appetite they
reduce vomiting their neuro protectants
they have anti-cancer roles antioxidant
antibacterial antifungal Antipa
resetting roles their anti-inflammatory
said to be as potent
a milligram of steroids there's
immunosuppressive roles that are very
useful and I see great responses in
people with with transplants of their
organs using cannabis not needing to use
as much of their immune modulating drugs
there are a number of dermatological FEX
that are very important there Branko
dilating as opposed to bronco
constricting so even though people might
use them as smoker vapor they're
actually opening up the airway is rather
than constricting them that's not to say
it's not an irritant to the airway but
because it is if Santa Coloma agent
anti-diabetic own stimulating so it
strengthens our bones with the
cannabinoid activation there are
anti-psychotic hang and the ings
ngo lytic or anxiety anti-anxiety
medicines they're antidepressants
they're vaso relaxants they allow blood
vessels to relax and carry more blood
they're anti ischemic in the first
studies that were done about cannabis
decades ago we learned that they can
protect from the size of a stroke
they're anticonvulsants and then they
have numerous roles in the
gastrointestinal tract they slow the
motility they reduce the secretions they
reduce stomach acid and they reduce
reflux they also help induce sleep they
they shorten this the duration of time
getting to sleep at night so the natural
cannabinoids are represented by these
two molecules they're actually more of
them but these are the predominant two
that are seen in the throughout the body
an and amide on the top and two AG on
the left the next slide shows the plant
cannabinoids they're at least three of
what are now counted to be between a
hundred and a hundred and forty
different cannabinoids in the cannabis
plant depends on where the strain has
grown and what the genes are like in
that particular area you'll see Delta 9
THC on the upper corner and CBD next to
it on the on the right hand side what
this is what I'm showing this to
indicate
is that there's a very subtle difference
here between these two molecules right
in this point of the Ring where a
hydrogen atom comes from one point of a
methyl group over to the oxygen
saturates that oxygen opens the ring and
thereby changes the shape of the
molecule ever so slightly it's all the
same atoms it's atomic weight is all the
same as well it's just a slightly
different configuration that does not
fit in the cannabinoid receptor quite
the same way so yes I can get into the
receptor but the CBD
doesn't activate the receptor it's work
is somewhere else the THC actually gets
into the receptor and very much like the
natural cannabinoids activates those
receptors to provide all of those
different effects the bottom was just
another example to show you something
about the structure activity
relationship the THC v is another plant
cannabinoid and you'll see right here at
the bottom the chain is a little bit
shorter it's three carbon chain as
opposed to a five carbon chain in THC
and I think that what we know about this
or is that THC Li gets into the
cannabinoid receptor but it doesn't
activate it unless it's in very high
concentration so by having a shorter
tail if you will or side chain it does
not have the same effect on the receptor
basically it acts like a mild blocker of
the receptor so this is a look at what
the receptor might be like on the left
hand screen we see dots which represent
amino acids so in the case of the cb1
receptor there are 472 amino acids that
are a small continuous chain and when it
clumps it makes a socket if you will
that moves from the inside of the cell
up into the membrane and there it's
ready for business
the cb2 receptor is the green dots and
it - as forms a receptor very much like
the cb1 receptor it's a little shorter
but it does basically the same thing
in that mobile group of cells that are
around the body it's known from the
basic research that if you change just
one of these amino acids in the chain
you can alter the function of the
receptor it does not work as well so the
structure of the receptor itself in very
subtle degree is is works better or
works less well depending on on really
the genetics of the receptor genes so
this has led us to understand that there
are in fact endocannabinoid deficiency
diseases so we can see this variability
in these endocannabinoid receptor genes
they're called snips or single
nucleotide polymorphisms and these
polymorphisms do affect the
functionality of the endocannabinoid
system for some people this
endocannabinoids system just doesn't
work as well as it does in some in
another person's endocannabinoid
receptor so this is a couple pages
listing some of the conditions that are
now implicated as cannabinoid receptor
polymorphisms starting from
schizophrenia and migraine multiple
sclerosis and other degenerative
diseases irritable bowel syndrome fail
failure to thrive the non organic
failure to thrive is also described as a
endocannabinoid deficiency anorexia
general motion a chronic motion sickness
fibromyalgia and a variety of menstrual
symptoms which might include severe pain
as well as endometriosis may be
endocannabinoid receptor abnormalities
seizure disorders even happiness has
been recognized as a condition that it
has a similar polymorphism of the
cannabinoid receptor depression and
other mood disorders alcohol dependence
obesity abd ADHD PTSD I haven't read the
papers on this list at the bottom here
but lipid profiles are different
in patients with different cannabinoid
receptors Mediterranean hypocaloric diet
is different the risk of cyclical
vomiting syndrome may be genetic and
marijuana demand I'm not quite sure what
that refers to I'll have to read that
paper but let's look at the way that the
cannabinoid receptors work in the
nervous system but in this case this is
showing a synapse between two nerve
cells one is the presynaptic cell
bringing the signal into the synapse and
then this the neurotransmitter in this
case is glutamate now whether it's
glutamate or adrenaline or noradrenaline
or dopamine or serotonin or
acetylcholine or gaba they all are the
same in terms of the role of cannabinoid
system they the cannabinoid receptors it
may be in these post in the presynaptic
cells and the cannabinoids are generated
on the postsynaptic cell so as we go
through this we're increasing the
glutamate in the receptor is beginning
to cross the cleft and activate the
glutamate receptor and and then transmit
the nerve impulse from the presynaptic
cell to the postsynaptic cell when this
begins to happen at least in a strong
degree the cannabinoids represented by
these shapes are generated they cross
the cleft in the opposite direction to
find the cannabinoid receptor and when
the cannabinoid receptor is activated it
blocks the production and the release of
the glutamate so it's a modulator for
the way that the nervous system is is
running it prevents excitotoxin from
exceeding the safe limits of what the
nerves can handle you can burn up the
nerves by over activating them so the
cannabinoids are there to protect the
nerves whether it's an excitatory
neurotransmitter as is the case in
glutamate or an inhibitory
neurotransmitter as in gaba the
cannabinoids are they're just the same
providing this retro act retroactive
messaging system the let the presynaptic
cell know
it should back off and stop producing
such a great amount of neurotransmitter
in the immune system it's not so easy to
demonstrate it with a graph but we know
some basic things we know for example
that there's abundant evidence that the
cannabinoids modulate the immune
responses whether you react or not is a
cannabinoid function research in South
Carolina has shown that THC as a single
molecule attenuates the boost versus
graft reaction possibly having a role in
transplant rejection is what they
surmised and in this bottom study this
was done in Mississippi and the infected
monkeys with the HIV like virus the
simian immunodeficiency virus and what
they found in those monkeys that got a
daily injection of Delta 9 THC basically
the main active ingredient in cannabis
is that it ameliorated disease
progression attenuated viral load and
tissue inflammation significantly
reducing the morbidity and the mortality
of the infected monkeys so we don't
exactly know how this occurs but we do
know that there's a protective role with
this particular infection
there are both synthetic and phyto
cannabinoid medications this turn a
banal has been on the market for about
20 years it's in three strengths it's
not particularly liked by people who use
the whole plant cannabis because the
plant feels a lot better than the
individual molecule of THC or in this
case a synthetic THC mab alone is
another synthetic THC and it too is on
the market I haven't seen it used before
Nabisco malls are plant cannabinoids but
they're not available in the United
States they are available in 30 other
nations as medicines but we have allowed
cannabidiol in a plant extract called
epidural x and it is available through
centers
specialize in seizure disorders where we
have been able to provide this to
children in particular with with the
seizure disorders that really cannot be
managed with conventional medications it
is 99% CBD is 1% non THC cannabinoids
I'd like to make a point of the fact
that once this plant produced this high
CBD product it went back to the
laboratory where they removed all of the
additional THC that was there because
there usually is about at least 5% THC
in these high CBD plants and they
removed it basically for political
purposes they want to see that this is
not going to contain any THC which is
continues to be vilified as a dangerous
drug when I'm treating kids with seizure
disorders I often will start with THC
and CBD or if I don't get the results
I'm looking for with the high CBD
products I'm going to add THC because th
C is a known anticonvulsant and works
very well if you add that to the CBD you
get a stronger anticonvulsant medicine
this is basically an argument for why
the whole plant works better than the
individual molecules and rather than
reading the whole thing I want to bring
you your attention to the 9 THC
components of the plant there are a lot
of components there not only these other
minor cannabinoids there are also
terpenes and their molecules that are
have have some relationship to
cannabinoids there are some terpenes
that actually get into the cannabinoid
receptor and can activate it such as
beta carry awfully and gets into the cb2
receptor and can activate that receptor
so there are molecules in the plant in
addition to the THC in the CBD that we
commonly talked about that have numerous
therapeutic properties in their own
right so they have for example neuro
protective roles bone stimulating roles
antipsychotic antiepileptic
antibacterial anti-diabetic vaso
relaxant anxiety candy spasmodic and
analgesic effects
the there is a host of pharmacologic
effects so that when the whole plant is
used you get a much stronger effect than
you do when you're just using single
molecule products and when given the
choice people uniformly will choose the
whole plant because it feels better and
it seems to work better than the
individual molecule the federal federal
government knows all about this for five
five years ago coming out of the NIH
these authors stated in their abstract
to their paper that modulating
endocannabinoid activity which is what
we're doing when we're using cannabis
may have therapeutic potential in almost
all diseases affecting humans strong
words and then the rest of the laundry
list of conditions that they cite
including obesity metabolic syndrome
diabetes and diabetic complications
neurodegenerative inflammatory
cardiovascular liver gastrointestinal
skin diseases pain psychiatric disorders
cachexia which is a wasting syndrome
cancer chemotherapy induced nausea and
vomiting and many others you know I
would be adding to that autoimmune
diseases insomnia and other conditions
where I really see in my practice that
cannabinoids are so beneficial in
modulating the endocannabinoids system
and helping with those problems as well
this is the federal patent on
cannabinoids is held by the Department
of Health and Human Services it was
applied for in 1999 and granted in 2003
so you can't make a cannabinoid as a
medicine unless you're given permission
by Health and Human Services and the
federal government there are natural
ways to up regulate the the
endocannabinoid system such as exercise
and massage and manipulation and
acupuncture these will briefly up
regulate your natural cannabinoids and
also the metabolic breakdown products of
acetaminophen and some of the NSAIDs are
recognized as up regulating your natural
cannabinoids by altering the metabolism
of the natural Metallica
of the cannabinoids you upregulate them
so it has a beneficial effect that may
at least in part be these medicines may
in part be from their role in affecting
the endocannabinoid system there are
various pathologic conditions that up
regulate the endocannabinoid system even
obesity up regulates the endocannabinoid
system these natural endocannabinoids
are activated and synthesized on-demand
as needed in the body then they're
rapidly metabolized right there at the
site of the action we do see some of
them floating in the bloodstream but by
and large they're active right at the
point where they're needed the plant the
plant cannabinoids however are broken
down exclusively in the liver in what's
called the cytochrome p450 metabolic
pathways and we do have genetic
differences in those pathways as well so
one person is going to inactivate
cannabis from the cannabis plant in a
few hours and another person is going to
take many hours we'll talk more about
this in a minute the one thing that I
think is particular important here is
that there are no significant drug drug
interactions between cannabis and
conventional pharmaceuticals with a rare
exception in a drug called Club Assam
which is metabolized by the same
metabolic pathway as the CBD is but
you've got to have a high dose of CBD
for this to be a problem and so if
people are on this particular
anticonvulsant or really I would suggest
other anticonvulsants and you're using a
high amount of CBD you should be looking
at your blood levels of those
anticonvulsants to be sure you're
getting them in the right range
otherwise
besides anticonvulsants there's no
significant drug drug interaction
between cannabis and any of the common
any of the pharmaceuticals better on the
market we can't expect a wide range in
blood
depending on a person's receptors and
their metabolic pathways so one dose is
not the same from one person to the next
this really shows up when treating
patients in a nursing facility for
Alzheimer's dementia where I see a
person might get a great effect with
five milligrams of THC in a in a usually
in a food like a chocolate or a little
snack and another person might take as
much as thirty milligrams or even 40
milligrams to get the effect that you're
desiring so our cannabinoid systems
don't work the same and we really have
to adjust the the amount of medicine
that we use in order to get the desired
effect this is a graph showing the
metabolism of smoked cannabis in
particular the THC molecule as the
dotted line the first pass metabolite
the one that is broken down at first in
the liver goes to this 11 hydroxy THC so
you see here after about five minutes
after smoking cannabis or vaporizing
cannabis you have a peak blood level
that rapidly drops down again over this
first hour so at an hour you can see
that probably close to 10% is all that
remains from the inhaled dose of
medicine the 11 hydroxy is the one that
is in this dashed line and it's produced
by the liver and does end up in the
bloodstream the solid line are the
inactive metabolites abbreviated as this
carboxy THC molecule on the straight
line so as the THC disappears in the 11
hydroxy GAC disappears we get this solid
line of the inactive metabolites that
last four days this is really only used
for useful for law enforcement because
these are inactive molecules they do
nothing for us pharmacologically so just
to review you get the most THC is
eliminated over the first hour but the
duration of action is over two to three
hours now looking
at the metabolism of ingested cannabis
we have quite a different curve now you
see that the inactive metabolite shows
up first and Peaks rapidly over a course
of about two hours the THC is the lowest
of these curves and the eleven hydroxy
is the greater one so something about
near 80% of the active ingredients is
actually this 11 hydroxy THC it's a
psychoactive molecule and the THC too so
for the first couple hours you peak on
the effect of ingested cannabis and then
it runs out 6 8 10 hours again depending
on your metabolism so someone with a
rapid metabolism may burn it all up in 5
hours and another person may take close
to 12 hours before they really break
down the cannabinoids to their inactive
forms this too has to play into the way
that we're teaching people how to use
cannabis as medicine for obvious reasons
so just to review this the ingested
cannabis the THC is eliminated over
about five to eight hours and the
duration of action I would say is more
like 5 to 10 hours there are a bunch of
other therapeutic considerations that
are important to consider when talking
about cannabis one of them is that
cannabis is described by natural paths
as an adaptogen so cannabis has any any
a unique ability to give us what we need
that is to say that if you were to use
cannabis at bedtime and go to sleep
after using it and find that your sleep
is is more prolonged and is more rapidly
you more rapidly get to sleep so
basically the quality and the duration
of sleep is markedly improved you would
also find that using the same cannabis
in the daytime is not going to put you
to sleep your body basically does what
you need and the cannabinoids are there
in that role the method of
administration is very important we have
topical uses of cannabis that can be
used for
skin lesions of all kinds and skin
diseases of various kinds beyond really
the scope of this presentation we have
mostly we speak of vapor and smoke on
one hand and ingested products on the
other hand so two major areas where
people use cannabis also people were
making suppositories out of cannabis and
we don't really know enough about this
to to advise it in most cases but there
are situations where a person might
choose to use a suppository where other
methods just aren't practical or
effective neutral versus acid
cannabinoids this brings two up to our
point something that I'll touch on as we
go forward in the next few slides but
suffice to say that the whole plant
green and growing in the yard the
cannabinoids are in an acid form and
it's not until they're they're heated
that we rapidly decarboxylate these
these acid forms into the neutral forms
of these molecules there's also the
topic of cannabis cannabinoid synergism
and I've somewhat alluded to this
earlier in saying that different
cannabinoids work together better than
they do alone single plant versus single
molecule CBD versus whole plant CBD
these are quite different and I don't
believe I've added a graph so I'll just
speak of that momentarily here if you
take a single molecule CBD product which
you might end up with if you're sourcing
it from offshore we don't really know
what's in those unless you take them
through the laboratory single molecule
CBD has a biphasic response curve that
is to say it may reduce pain and
inflammation very nicely up to a point
that as you go up higher on the dose
that will disappear again
so as biphasic meaning it goes one way
and then it goes another so we choose to
use CBD rich medicines that are grown as
whole plant medicine
sport for this CBD rich products and
those don't exhibit that biphasic
response you can take a bigger dose and
you get a bigger effect we do want to be
able to select cultivars and kima bars
as we go into this new era of more and
more adult use of marijuana and
marijuana preferred for medical use what
we have come to realize is we just have
a lot of different chemicals in these
products that don't necessarily tell us
what we're getting if we're just looking
at THC and CBD there's some studies
coming out of Israel that are very
telling in treating autistic kids and
that is to say that a very high CBD
product about 20 to 1 CBD to THC was
working great for treating autistic kids
and then suddenly the caregivers said
what you do is not working because we're
anxious they were aggressive it just
seemed like they were back to square
zero and what they found was that even
though the THC and the CBD were
basically identical in these two
products there were many many other
constituents that were quite different
and ret you know I'm I don't even know
the names of these cannabinoids but in
one it was very high and in another it
was very low or vice-versa so there are
subtleties of these cannabis cultivars
that we don't understand yet there's too
many variables to simplify oversimplify
our supreme court in a decision about 15
years ago said that cannabis is a
fungible crop I didn't know the term
fungible means it's interchangeable with
any other cannabis like a bushel of corn
or a bushel of wheat it's no different
from one location to the other
but in cannabis it is it is not a
fungible crop and it can't be
necessarily substituted between one
cannabis strain and another so this
we're learning a great deal but we have
a long way to go in understanding what
might be best for which can
if somebody says that they know the best
strain for the for any particular
condition they're guessing or there's an
anecdote to say that it seemed to work
in one person but as far as really
understanding the chemical nature and
what's causing one strain to work and
one to not work as well we don't know
the answers to those questions there's
another topic here tolerance and
autoregulation that's very important and
it really takes me back to that image of
the of the receptor in the cell membrane
what we know is that there's a
population of these receptors in the
cells of the brain in the in these brain
neurons and that as cannabis is used on
a regular basis the what happens is that
some of these receptors will come out of
the cell membrane where they're there to
receive the cannabinoids and they'll
come back inside the cell inactive
they're ready to be used again if you're
not using cannabis but the body will
auto regulate the population of our
cannabinoid receptors and when this
occurs we don't feel as high under the
influence of cannabis so a chronic
cannabis user often will tell you I'm
not really getting high I'm just feeling
relaxed I'm reducing my pain I'm I'm
doing the things that they might be
using it for so it's really a matter of
changing the population of these
receptors to where you don't feel high
any longer and this was really well
demonstrated by a patient of mine who
went home with intentions to work over a
course of a month up to a very high dose
to see if it would work on a on a
difficult cancer and when he went home
he just decided I'm all-in and he took
the whole large dose on the first dose
he was wiped he was on the couch now
you'd used it in his youth so he wasn't
frightened but he had to just sleep it
off and a day later he took a gram of
concentrated cannabis oil again and the
third day he did the same and each day
thereafter he did the same taking this
very large dose all the while being
basically a lump on the couch
totally incapacitated but with this
autoregulation and tolerance developing
it took about five to seven days and he
was up and round and acting normally
again so even though he could still take
the gram of cannabis oil every day he
was not feeling particularly stoned
after he had had this tolerance
developed so methods of administration I
think this is very useful to understand
smoke and vapor have a bioavailability
ranging from two to 56% in the studies
done by Huestis back in 2007 in another
study it was in a range of 10 to 25% but
again a vast range of how much ends up
actually in the bloodstream bioavailable
so you can imagine that if somebody is
sort of casually puffing on it on a
cannabis joint and they don't really
want to get high they may just blow it
out very readily and not absorb much not
get much into the lungs on the other
hand somebody that's drawing it in
slowly and deeply and holding it in the
lungs may absorb as more than half of
the available cannabinoids that are in
the camp plant matter so you can get a
much higher degree of bioavailability
just by the method that you use this
method of smoking and vaporizing gets
these molecules into the bloodstream by
way of this the lungs and not going by
the digestive tract through the liver
first and then into the bloodstream so
we say that this avoids first pass
metabolism in oral forms we say that the
bioavailability is 10 to 20 percent this
is probably pretty accurate which is to
say any dose if you're measuring all the
milligrams of cannabinoids that amount
that actually get into the bloodstream
before the liver breaks them down as I
was showing you in that carboxy THC
solid line on the graphs the
bioavailability is really quite reduced
to about 10 or 20 percent we can't
really do anything about this I would
say in general don't eat cannabis
products on a full stomach
or a big meal at the same time it may
facilitate absorption to have a small
fatty meal to get better absorption now
in Huestis is work she says that
bioavailability of rectal or vaginal
suppositories of cannabis are somewhere
near twice the oral route of absorption
with a lower first pass metabolism what
this means is that when a suppository is
in the rectal tissue it's in a watershed
zone between the vessels that go back up
to the liver first and those that go
around into the vena cava and back
directly to the heart so we're right in
a watershed in in drainage area in the
body and so we do avoid some of this
first pass metabolism by the liver when
using an in suppository the thing that
is really not shown here is that these
studies on bioavailability of
suppositories were done 20 years ago by
a Mahmood elf solely down at the
Mississippi farm well I'm not sure if it
was there that he did the research where
cannabis has grown for the federal
government but what he what he was
discovering was THC as a single molecule
is not absorbed and that we don't really
have studies on looking at cannabis as a
plant oil or a whole plant extract so
what he did was devised the best
molecule to get it absorbed and it
happens to be one called a Hemi
succinate ester of THC so you're binding
THC to a Hemi succinate molecule that is
readily absorbed and it would make a
great medicine but none of these are
being produced for commercial use and I
mentioned before we have topical and
transdermal use both are very different
one is not getting through the skin and
just treating skin conditions topically
the other is designed with with solvents
to get through the skin and be available
as a systemic medication this is going
back to that point I was making earlier
about the whole plant the cannabinoids
are in the acid form and it's
withdrawing and heating that there
decarboxylated this is what's happening
thca is as this molecule is called a
carboxyl moiety right here stuck to the
THC as you heat it it comes off as co2
and you end up with THC prolonged drying
and storage of cannabis you'll get a lot
of decarboxylation occurring so that the
the advantage in THC a is that when used
when it's green and fresh is not
psychoactive it's a different molecule
that has different properties we don't
really know that much about it yet THC
we know much more about it is
psychoactive so people are using
products that are designed with acid
forms because they aren't psychoactive
spoke of synergism earlier dr. Kostas
work in Italy many years ago showed that
wrasse show a great response to THC and
a CBD but if they're both used together
is a stronger medicine still so you get
again a better effect from a combination
of molecules than you do as a single
molecule and MacAllister and Marc who
did a paper in San Francisco in 2010
looking at glioblastoma brain tumor
cells and this is one of the graphs that
they showed in their paper what they've
done is they've taken brain tumor cells
called a glioblastoma and they've taken
a small concentration of THC and added
it to a tube of tumor cells and here
this hundred percent is just nutrient
the second column is adding that much
THC and it knocks the viability of the
cells this much the CBD is added at this
small proportion and our concentration
and it knocks the number of two brain
tumor cells down this much and when you
put the two together here's the
viability of the cells so my point is
simply again THC and CBD work much
better together than they do alone we
don't really have a particular ratio
that would be best for many
clinical trials this would have to be
done as a different experiment coming to
the end of my talk before questions I
just wanted to show one particular case
and this was a 16 month-old child that
was brought to me by his parents when he
was diagnosed with a large brain tumor
this is called an optic tract glioma is
the white mass that we see that it was
found in August of 2011 right there is
such a large tumor that surgeon said I'm
sorry we can't touch that it's just
simply too big and too deeply seated in
the brain they talked to the radio
radiation Doc's and they said we have a
treatment for you they talked to the
chemotherapy Doc's and they said to that
we have a treatment for you but both
admitted that they weren't going to
necessarily kill the tumor and they
couldn't really say that it wouldn't
cause harm to his developing brain so
they found me and we started to use this
concentrated cannabis oil that I spoke
of a minute ago with this other cancer
patient squirting a bit of oil onto his
pacifier twice a day this was a solo act
of treatment there was no other
radiation chemotherapy and other than
just a great diet and largely vegan diet
that was the only thing that they did so
you'll see three months after the
initial presentation his MRIs showed a
faint faint
image of the tumor it was just melting
away if you will and then after two more
months
it was virtually gone he has continued
to go along year after year up to the
present time with no recurrence
while still using a maintenance dose of
cannabis this kiddo as bright as can be
and he's really fun to sit in the office
and talk with when he was still well let
me there was a bit more of a story here
one of the parts of the story is the
doctors don't know the truth of what the
patients did they see these images and
they call him a miracle baby because
they don't know that cannabis was used
the family is frightened of the
possibility that Child Protective
Services will come out and take their
child away so no one really knows who
this
baby is we do see that when this kiddo
entered school last year as a first
grader he was taken for IQ testing and
his IQ comes back at 135
so everybody is quite delighted with the
fact that he's thriving and doing so
well
and no not showing any sign of the tumor
after all of these years again it's just
a maintenance dose of cannabis that
we're using and in general I would
recommend that for any cancer that we
would be treating so that's the gist of
the presentation up till this point I
thank you for your attention and I look
forward to your questions
thank you dr. Herman rather for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on this send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation so
let's get started with our first
question one moment okay the first
question asks what about damage to the
developing brain in pregnancy nursing
mothers and adolescents well that's an
excellent question and a question that
the National Institute on Drug Abuse is
really charged with looking for harm so
there has been a lot of funding going
into looking for harm in the developing
brain but really our first knowledge of
this comes from studies that as a study
that was done by a doctor Melanie Dreier
when she went to Jamaica back in the 80s
and 90s she collected 30 pregnant women
that were heavy cannabis users and 30
control women and what she found was
that the labor delivery and that first
neonatal month of life was marked by
very healthy looking kids coming from
mom's that used cannabis and in fact
they seemed to be more alert and and
developing even better than the babies
that came from the moms that weren't
using cannabis her initial studies were
published in Pediatrics magazine when
she went back years later to see how the
kids were doing the kids from the moms
that were pot smokers were still doing
better the Pediatrics Journal was
unwilling to publish her findings they
basically said that it may be an earth
mother phenomenon where perhaps those
thirty moms that were pot smokers were
just better mom better mothers but
looking for harm in the developing brain
has been an area of study for quite a
long time now one of the studies came
out of do need in in southern island of
New Zealand the study was produced in
2012 and it showed a positive
association between adolescent onset of
cannabis use and what they said was a
decline in the IQ from this study dr.
Nora Volkow our and our NightA director
surmised that there is a neurotoxic
effect of cannabis on the developing
brain that permanently lowers IQ well
she says that frequently I've heard her
say it on occasion but within a year
there was a viral berg which was talking
about a review of this same very study
at the University of Oxford they looked
at the same data and said that these
conclusions are premature in light of
likely confounding from socioeconomic
status and another researcher may air in
also suggested that the data the
conclusions from this data by the
original authors overestimated and even
could be zero as far as a cannabis
effect on the IQ of the patients studied
then brain structure has been studied
rather extensively intensively in the
last few years
in 2008 down in Australia you cell
looked at the developing brain and he
suggested from MRI scans that young
people heavy daily cannabis users he
said that the cannabis exerted harmful
effects on the brain tissue and mental
health so what he's looking at is the or
the gray matter organs of the brain and
saying that there's evidence from their
study that there was a difference in
these of in the gray matter between the
cannabis smokers and the non cannabis
smoker controls but what he didn't
really do was check to see whether this
proposed gray matter changed the brain
was really showing any harm or mental
illness that was not really being it was
being asserted but it wasn't being
really tested for following this now
NIDA and the National Institute of drug
abuse has gone on to look at a couple
other studies that they have funded and
one by Gillman and all in 2014 that they
often will quote it's often quoted that
compared to twenty recreational
comparing twenty recreational cannabis
users to twenty controls by looking at
their brain images they concluded that
there were differences in the shape and
in the volume of the left nucleus
accumbens and Magilla a couple very
important organs in the brain no
decrease in performance was studied just
the assertions of harm from the cannabis
they did admit at the end of the study
that those subjects that were the pot
smokers were also more likely to be
drinking alcohol so NIDA went into
another study and a year later done by
Weiland and all in 2015 they did a
larger and a better controlled study now
with 50 daily cannabis users and 59
users as well as 29 adults and 29 adult
non adults both users and 29 non users
and they said that there was no
statistically significant
differences found in bees and the other
brain structures
besides the amygdala and the nucleus
accumbens they said that when carefully
controlling for alcohol use no changes
in the brain were found this study is
seldom quoted by the National Institute
on Drug Abuse showing basically no harm
and really implicating alcohol and other
drugs as a more risk and then going back
to look at things like short-term memory
by a researcher by the name of Polk
short-term memory loss virtually
disappears with brief periods of
cannabis abstinence and then in what's
called a meta-analysis by Shriner in
2012 they found no residual effects on
cognitive performance in the cannabis
smokers again with with just abstinence
there's a study by Hooper in 2014 on
cognate cognitive performance in
adolescents and they reported in 33
subjects abstaining from cannabis that
there were no differences in IQ
attention or memory and 2015 looking at
the grade point averages meir reported
that lower grade point averages
associated with cannabis usage lost
statistical significance when
controlling for alcohol and tobacco
usage and finally I would just add
another study in 2016 by maka retz and
all and they said that IQ or performance
differences in teens were not found
associated with cannabis users compared
to cigarette smoking or other confounds
so in doing harm studies unless you're
really controlling well for Alcohol
Tobacco and other dangerous substances
you really can't see what's going on
with the cannabis and when you do
control for that it appears that
cannabis is not harming the infants and
children that are exposed to cannabis
thanks for that question oh my pleasure
well thank you for
the answer then the next question asks
what about impairment in driving when
using cannabis well this is an excellent
question because I do talk with
employers and they're concerned about
their employees using cannabis on the
job we also are concerned about people
driving there are no simple road tests
for impairment for cannabis and there's
a vast differences in the amount of
cannabis that a person can have in their
system again depending on tolerance that
I spoke about earlier so this is you
know I think the way to look at this is
like any other drug this is the only
really reasonable way to look at it we
don't tell people that are using opioids
or benzodiazepines or sleeping pills or
any other kind of medicine
antipsychotics we don't tell them that
they can't drive the car and if they are
stopped and not performing well driving
they generally are not going to be taken
from their car and have their card towed
away so this is being proposed now as a
way to deal with doings roadside
screening of cannabis users simply to
take their cars away it's really
illogical because there there is there
are studies that are showing that
cannabis use in driving is really
dependent on how comfortable you are
with cannabis and how tolerant you have
become to cannabis so for a new user of
cannabis experimenting with cannabis
don't get behind the wheel it's not the
time to be driving you will be spaced
out and you might forget where you're
going or or you know just not be driving
well in general the drivers that are
using cannabis drive slower they don't
follow behind cars as closely and
generally speaking they're safe drivers
there was an interesting study that came
out of the National Highway Traffic
Safety Association in 2010 it was a
double-blind
study placebo-controlled with 20 heavy
cannabis users and what they were doing
was assessing the impact of alcohol and
THC on these on these people's ability
to critically track meaning staying in
their Lane
a divided attention and in a stop signal
task where you've got to be able to
break at the proper time and in
cognition and the conclusions of this
NHTSA study was that alcohol
significantly impairs those driving
tasks and THC did not affect those tasks
performances so the present study
generally confirms that heavy cannabis
users developed tolerance to the
impairing effects of THC on
neurocognitive cast performance I just
encourage people to be smart about
cannabis use and my patients will come
and say to me oh if I use cannabis in
the morning I'm gonna be sure to not
drive for the next few hours and I think
that's generally safe and wise to do
other people do use cannabis driving and
are rather safe drivers and if you look
throughout the literature you'll find
that to be true as well thanks for that
question
well if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr.
hurricane gather for his presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I'd like to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when that webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thanks for joining us and we hope to see
you again here soon at lab roots goodbye